[Musique]
bonjour à tous merci de nous retrouver
pour ce nouveau numéro de VIP
aujourd'hui j'ai le plaisir de recevoir
un jeune historien et un auteur qui
s'appelle Pierre-Louis Lancel
Pierre-Louis Lancel bonjour bonjour
Merci d'être sur le plateau de TV 78 on
va parler d'un livre absolument
passionnant du fait surtout que ça parle
de câlins qu'on connaît pas très bien le
duc du Maine qui est le fils préféré
Louis XIV voilà quelqu'un qu'on connaît
pas très bien et qui pourtant a une vie
absolument extraordinaire et qui révèle
énormément de choses sur son époque déjà
c'est aussi l'intérêt de ce livre avant
je vais mieux vous présenter alors vous
vous avez eu le prix de la biographie de
la ville d'Hossegor
voilà et après le prix histoire 2021 de
la Fondation Stéphane Bern pour
l'histoire et le patrimoine Institut de
France bravo
ensuite donc vous êtes un jeune
historien et vous êtes un auteur alors
auteur de ce de ce livre aussi auteur à
la radio vous pouvez me dire un petit
peu ce que vous faites en quelques mots
oui bien sûr donc ça fait à peu près 7
ans que mon travail principal en dehors
d'écrire des livres et d'écrire des
émissions de radio pour les émissions de
Franck Ferrand d'abord sur Europe 1 et
aujourd'hui sur Radio Classique c'est
une émission quotidienne au coeur de
l'histoire au cœur de l'histoire sur
Europe 1 et donc Franck Ferran sur Radio
Classique et il y a pas de souci et
oui donc ça consiste je l'ai suivi et ça
consiste et très intéressant parce que
ça consiste tous les jours à découvrir
une nouvelle histoire dans l'Histoire et
je pense que c'est une excellente porte
d'entrée pour découvrir la complexité de
toutes les de toutes les périodes mais
aussi leur ressemblance à quel point
finalement les histoires les pardon les
époques se suivent et se ressemblent les
répétitions les répétitions et le fait
qu'il y a un éternel humain qui existe
et qui est finalement exactement les les
personnes surtout quand elles sont
proches du pouvoir sont mises dans des
situations
extrêmement fortes ou ça leur bateau
tangue beaucoup si vous permettez
métaphore et là ils doivent réagir ils
sont face à des dilemmes et je pense que
être comme ça incarné l'histoire comme
le fait Franck Ferrand merveilleusement
permet de rentrer dans l'histoire c'est
une excellente première marche vers une
histoire peut-être plus académique qui
est aussi passionnante d'accord est-ce
que c'est en travaillant pour la radio
en faisant vos recherches que vous avez
découvert ce duc du Maine ou pas du tout
comment comment se choix s'est-il fait
alors c'est au cours de mes études
universitaires c'est même avant en fait
tout a commencé par un livre de
Françoise Chandernagor l'année du roi
qui raconte là aussi avec un talent
absolument fou
la destinée de Madame de Maintenon qui a
un des personnages les plus romanesques
de l'histoire de France et je voyais
dans dans ce roman apparaître ça et là
le personnage de duc Dumaine j'ai un
petit peu creusé et je me suis rendu
compte que c'était quelqu'un qui avait
pareil une vie absolument incroyable
c'est à dire que sa vie aussi est un
roman oui
surtout une vie hors norme enfin qui lui
est arrivé à lui n'est arrivé à personne
d'autre exactement sa position très
particulière sur laquelle on va revenir
exactement en tant que fils de Louis XIV
et en même temps bâtard donc il y a
cette contradiction cet homme est une
contradiction vivante pour ses
contemporains et ça c'est passionnant et
alors du coup oui toutes ces fondations
sont un petit peu on a l'impression que
c'est un peu fondé sur du sable quoi
c'est Louis XIV veut le mettre vraiment
en avant mais on va peut-être revenir
avant sur justement madame de monter
span qui est la maîtresse de Louis XIV
voilà maintenant
de nombreux enfants voilà dont le duc du
Maine qui va être l'ainé de ses enfants
survivants voilà et Louis XIV lui-même
comme enfant légitime n'en a plus qu'un
exactement et surtout Louis XIV aime ses
enfants mais c'est ça il aime ses
enfants illégitimes et ses enfants
illégitimes il confie leur éducation à
une un personnage qui s'appelle à
l'époque madame Scarron qui est un
personnage un très très secondaire à
l'époque la veuve Caron qui va devenir
Madame de Maintenon qui va au roi et
leur rapprochement se fait autour du duc
du Maine donc déjà on a ce duc du Maine
qui sert un petit peu de catalyseur à
une histoire d'estime une histoire
d'amour peut-être voilà il a épousé tout
de même entre Louis XIV qu'il va épouser
et ça ça se passe quand le duc du Maine
à 13 ans d'accord
était vincée et ce qui est aussi très
intéressant dans dans l'enfance du duc
du Maine c'est qu'il est un petit peu
tiraillé entre ces deux femmes entre
Madame de Montespan d'une part et Madame
de Maintenon d'autre part deux femmes
qui sont extrêmement brillantes qui sont
des personnages parmi les plus
intéressants de leur époque et lui va
faire le choix de sa mère de cœur de sa
gouvernante de Madame de Maintenon oui
parce que ça sa mère biologique il ne
voit pas il la voit pas beaucoup au
début dans les ses premières années il
la voit beaucoup mais il va avoir
beaucoup plus d'estime pour Madame de
Maintenon qu'il juge beaucoup plus
raisonnable là où il a tendance à penser
semble-t-il que sa mère Madame de
Montespan n'est pas assez raisonnable
d'accord et puis après il a beaucoup de
soucis de santé
dans les Pyrénées
comme une mère et elle va l'aimer toute
sa vie comme une mère et lui il va
l'aimer toute sa vie comme il aimerait
une mère d'accord et alors du coup Louis
XIV là dedans il est il a une infection
pour ses enfants illégitimes oui et
particulièrement pour le duc du Maine
comment ça se fait parce que déjà le duc
du Maine est un enfant absolument
charmant c'est c'est l'enfant qu'on a
envie d'aimer il a plein d'esprit il a
des des petites phrases que Madame de
Sévigné relève dans sa correspondance il
est très mignon il est il est blond
enfin il est absolument charmant on
l'appelle le mignon on l'appelle le
minion d'ailleurs donc tout est dit et à
7 ans et en plus il boîte ce qui fait
que
et
Louis XIV va tout faire pour l'établir
et va tout faire pour faire de lui un
vrai prince c'est à dire un petit peu
pour effacer petit à petit la trace de
la batardise et ça va être tout le défi
de la vie du duc du Maine de devenir un
vrai prince un vrai prince qu'il ne peut
pas être mais non c'est savoureuse
saboter à la base quoi enfin voilà parce
qu'il est né d'un mariage d'un double
adultère et ça aux yeux de la de la
société de cours c'est absolument
terrible est-ce pour ça que saint-simo
attend de haine pour lui oh oui
sentiment c'est quelqu'un qui est donc
qui lui est un duc donc il est déjà un
très très haut niveau et qui est très
fier de son statut de duc et il a
beaucoup de mal à accepter qu'il y ait
des transgressions sociales exactement
ça le dérange que finalement le duc du
Maine passe largement devant l'éduquée
père comme lui alors que à son sens sa
naissance est beaucoup trop pour qu'il
puisse devenir un vrai prince donc je
comprends pour Saint-Simon le duc du
Maine incarne et tout ce dont il a
horreur et il fait pas aussi ce qui lui
fait peur et il aime pas la personnalité
du duc Dumaine il lui reconnaît beaucoup
de qualité d'ailleurs il est le premier
à dire que le duc du Maine est très
intelligent etc mais il peint tout en
noir c'est à dire qu'il dit que le duc
du Maine adolesprit mais pas comme un
ange il a de l'esprit comme un démon
donc voilà on est dans cette dans ce
genre de dénigrement perpétuel et tous
les événements de la vie du duc du Maine
sont interprétés par Saint-Simon à
charge et ça c'est assez fascinant de de
voir comment d'autres témoins qui
racontent la même scène que raconte
Saint Simon la raconte de manière
totalement différente sous un autre
angle positif plus positif ou neutre
mais en tout cas sans se dénigrement
permanent que ton sentiment a fait
preuve et alors il va il va même avoir
envie d'être militaire tellement il a
envie de plaire à son père parce que à
l'époque le premier devoir de la
noblesse c'est de se battre c'est de
défendre le royaume et évidemment pour
être un vrai prince dans l'idéal il
faudrait que le duc du Maine soit un
grand commandeur militaire et malgré sa
condition physique malgré sa condition
physique on le met à la cavalerie tout
simplement donc sur un cheval il y a
plus de problème et Louis XIV vraiment
lui donne des des charges très très
importantes très très tôt et ce qui fait
que il devient en gros général alors
qu'il a 20-25 ans c'est déjà quelqu'un
de très important d'un point de vue
militaire et il est mis dans des
situations de décision aux armées or le
duc du Maine est aussi quelqu'un qui n'a
pas beaucoup confiance en Lui c'est
quelqu'un qui doute il y a toujours ce
problème de légitimité et donc prendre
des décisions un petit peu dans dans
face à une grande pression
dans l'urgence c'est quelque chose qui
est difficile pour lui il a été préparé
d'un point de vue
on lui a on lui a donné un gouverneur
qui lui
mais il est quand même élevé à peu près
comme un prince d'accord mais il sait au
fond de lui qu'il n'est pas totalement
un prince on a toujours ce dilemme
incroyable ça ferait un film incroyable
histoire tellement originale
et bravo c'est juste passionnant et
encore plein de choses à dire mais le
mieux c'est de le lire voilà c'est
vraiment vraiment passionnant c'est ce
personnage est très attachant et il
arrive plein de choses tout le temps il
a énormément défauts et c'est ça aussi
c'est un vrai c'est un vrai personnage
oui humain un vrai humain voilà et on va
parler aussi donc vous serez au salon
histoire de les 19 et 20 novembre et
vous serez aussi le en tant que coteur
vous allez enfin je pense que c'est
Franck Ferrand qui va le présenter ce
livre là le roi de France tous les deux
je pense qu'on sera on sera à côté
Franck Ferrand il y a et il y a aussi
Anaïs Sautreuil voilà vous l'avez écrit
à trois mains
voilà c'est c'est quoi l'angle il y a 14
rois de France 15 pardon l'idée c'était
de justement présenter 15 rois de France
pourquoi
il a fallu faire un choix qui n'a pas
été facile
on a essayé de prendre ceux qui nous ont
semblés les plus intéressants tout
simplement ou les plus marquants dans
l'histoire de France c'est pour ça que
on parle évidemment d'un louis XIV d'un
Louis XV mais on parle aussi de roi
qu'on attendrait moins qui sont moins
connus et je pense à Louis VII par
exemple Louisette la plupart des gens ne
savent pas bien qui c'est et c'est bien
normal non non mais tout à fait normal
et moi j'ai appris plein plein de choses
en écrivant son portrait
Louis VII qui souvent est perçu comme un
personnage aussi un petit peu terne et
qui en fait a été très importante dans
son époque et enfin voilà donc il a
fallu faire ce choix et on déroule comme
ça 15 port on se les ai répartis 5
chacun et on s'est beaucoup amusé à
écrire ce livre et en fait ce que dit
Franck Ferrand c'est ces rois ont
participé à l'homogénéité du peuple
français ils essayaient de niveler soit
enfin niveler quoi voilà et ça a donné
cette société française que les autres
dans d'autres pays on faisait pas ça
alors je dirais que la démarche à moi en
tout cas elle me paraît passionnante
pour deux raisons il y a ce que vous
dites c'est à dire le côté construction
d'un itinéraire de l'itinéraire d'un
peuple d'un peuple et d'une entité qui
s'appelle la France voilà et ça chaque
croix apporte sa pierre et on a pour moi
l'autre aspect très intéressant qui est
un aspect plus individuel c'est à dire
des individus qui sont rois et le fait
qu'il soit roi signifie qu'ils sont
placés dans une situation qu'on pourrait
dire paroxystique hors norme et
quelle que soit leur caractère quel que
soit leur qualité et leurs énormes
défauts ils doivent composer avec ça et
tenir l'État et ça c'est absolument
passionnant je parlais de Louis VII tout
à l'heure Louis VII qui n'était
peut-être pas quelqu'un qui avait le
caractère qu'on enfin qui a le caractère
qu'on peut imaginer pour un roi le
charisme autorité de charisme
extraordinaire le le la vaillance
incroyable le l'autorité l'autorité etc
Louis VII c'est quelqu'un qui a composé
avec ses qualités et ses défauts et qui
a si vous me passez l'expression tenu la
boutique
bravo alors Pierre-Louis Lancel un grand
merci c'est passionnant voilà j'ai adoré
ce livre à très vite au salon ou
ailleurs et pour un autre livre
peut-être une autre biographie c'est
votre travail d'historien alors on y va
merci beaucoup au revoir au revoir à
tous merci de nous avoir suivi à bientôt
pour un autre VIP
[Musique]